le québec depuis la révolution
tranquille pendant 40 ans c'est
programmé en fonction d'un très grand
objectif celui de devenir une société
politiquement souveraine avec des
projets libéraux progressistes qui
allait
faire de notre société quelque chose de
bien quelque chose dessin et qui nous
inspirait de la fierté et tout cela a
été détruit par les deux échecs
référendaires
vivons les débris de la défaite que nous
nous sommes infligé nous mais non plus
c'est encore pire est encore pire les
deux défaites référendaires ont eu des
conséquences considérables sur justement
je serai la transformation du national
[Applaudissements]
les période référendaire étaient des
périodes très chaude mais gare au
nationalisme québécois et il ya un
documentaire qui sera présenté demain
sur nos ondes qui refait le parcours de
ce nationalisme québécois et soumet
trajectoire donc d'une évolution vers un
certain nationalisme décrit par gérard
bouchard vers un nationalisme plus
identitaire je reçois la réalisatrice
francine pc bond sera simplifiée et
protagonistes acquis qui ont fait porter
d'infos le héros de ce nationalisme
identitaire conseiller de pauline marois
de l'équipe des discours la fameuse
charte des valeurs qui a fait tant
parler dans ces questions dans ce
documentaire bonsoir vous dis merci
d'avoir accepté l'invitation pourquoi ce
documentaire français d'avoir ce que
c'est un documentaire à thèze pour vous
un documentaire important pour vous
situer pour vous il ya une longue
évolution j'ai pas le temps de vous
raconter toutes les péripéties et
commencer c'est parti d'une chose pour
aboutir à ça mais c'est à dire que je
trouve que c'est un sujet absolument
important j'ai moi même découvert plein
de choses en faisant le documentaire
dont notamment la blessure que j'avais
moi-même sous-estimé par rapport aux
échecs référendaires
c'est vraiment là que je pense je pense
que jacques et moi on se concentre là
dessus c'est qu'à partir du dernier
référendum notamment que la mentalité
d'assiégé le fait d'être obligé de se
sentir un peu plus vulnérables on allait
vers quelque chose de grand tous
découvrent louise beaudoin elle explique
tout d'un coup on est réduit à un état
de province et le sait la nature humaine
de vouloir se protéger et de soutenir
dans son coin parce que dans ces deux
référendums c'est dans le documentaire
on s'est dit non
à nous mêmes les québécois on reprend la
fameuse déclaration de monsieur parizeau
sur des votes ethniques etc y aurait eu
la jambe gauche pas une sorte de
dévolution de transition et on le voit
avec les lois 21 96 en ce moment vers un
nationalisme plus
identitaire c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
au fond ce que s'est passé autour du
référendum les 95 un peu avant un peu
après c'est un espèce de surgissement de
mauvaise conscience a dit que les
québécois francophones qui avaient voté
oui qui était très nationalistes se sont
demandés si effectivement leur projet
était légitime on en sort on leur disait
qu' il était un petit peu réfractaires
aux droits des minorités ont leur
rappeler la triste mémoire du chanoine
groulx les discours d' harry baur à ça
et tout le reste et les québécois ont
fini par intégrer un espèce de mauvaise
conscience en se disant on va montrer
patte blanche on va montrer que le
projet là il est civique pleinement
démocratique très ouvert et évidemment
dans cette opération et l'on peut dire
que le pain à duke est un peu loin de
dire que romande et non de désincarné ce
projet complètement à force de dire si
vite pluriel est ouvert il avait perdu
son centre de gravité
c'est à dire que ce projet là on n'a pas
de sens sans l'existence d'une majorité
francophone majorité historique sinon
évidemment de quoi on parle et cette
majorité est là elle ne parvenait plus à
dire nous à s'affirmer elle-même s
effacer c'était très paradoxal il
fallait au fond mais ouais mais c'est
relève admis mais certains dans le film
10 se noue là est un identitaire et d'un
bien qui dit 5,6 et xénophobe au fond
c'est pas le nook inaugurer le lancement
de la gamme
cette crise des accommodements
raisonnables
il ya vraiment un jeu de dominos est ce
que le film raconte il ya l'échec
référendaire ensuite ce que j'en dis
cette mentalité des d'incriminer on
devient plus + diversiterre que le pape
si on peut dire et ensuite eu un
mouvement contraire dans les universités
où on commence à remettre à regarder le
passé ce qu'on n'avait pas fait depuis
la révolution tranquille et ensuite la
crise des accommodements raisonnables
bien bâtir là-dessus et c'est un moment
clé où on parle à partir de ce moment là
que il faut garder les certaines
personnes dans des sous en fait il faut
les contrôler quoi ils sont on l'avait
jamais vu c'est un changement radical du
secours et pour la première fois le
nationalisme ce n'est plus un projet
d'autonomie ce n'est plus un projet qu
on conjugue avec le fédéral sa déduction
le territoire de viella laïcité ça
devient synonyme de la laïcité alors ya
vraiment quelque chose qui bascule à ce
moment là et ça continue jusqu'à ce jour
lorsque dans le film on voit madame
marois qui alors est dans l'opposition
présente sa loi sur la laïcité quand
elle reviendra au pouvoir en 2012 elle
présentera la charte des valeurs et elle
elle fait des discours elle dit nous est
le voeu plurielle et inclusif mais ça ne
convainc pas jacques beauchemin ça ne
veut pas convaincu semble-t-il quand on
entend les témoignages dans le
documentaire en toi et jacques se
sentent exclus mais ce très bon de la
langue et les styles et c'est très très
malheureux parce que le new de pauline
marois et de toute cette mouvance
politique autour d'elle à l'époque
c'était nous les québécois c'est pas
nous les canadiens français si nous les
québécois c'est tout le québec dont leur
coeur est formé par la majorité
historique francophone évidemment qu'ils
appellent à elles toutes les composantes
de la société québécoise pour former le
peuple québécois alors on a beaucoup
imputé à ce nous d des velléités de
fermeture de repli sur le monde
canadiens-français expression
d'exclusion savoir alors même que en
réalité il s'agissait d'une façon de
nommer le peuple québécois sans occulter
sa composante majoritaire c'était ça
l'idée et puis bon est-ce que ça a été
bien reçue malheureux su bien compris
peut-être pas je pense qu'on a un
extrait de monsieur legault qui citait
d'un excès que vous avez dans le film en
2019 au moment de déposer la loi sur la
laïcité mais de son adoption l'écoutent
québec ça fait longtemps qu'on a décidé
de séparer la religion et l'état et ça
fait plus de dix ans qu'on déborde des
signes religieux il est temps de fixer
des règles parce qu'au québec c'est
comme ça qu'on vit concrètement le
changer quoi la loi 21 j'ai l'impression
que beaucoup de divisions dans les vingt
dernières années puis qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose mais que les choses
qui ont été faites étaient tellement
superficiel c'était comme des paillettes
pour dire ben voilà on a fait quelque
chose alors qu'au final ça a des effets
concrets sur des groupes marginalisés et
ça m'apporte rien aux groupes dominants
ça apporte rien à la majorité des
québécois à part le sentiment de dominer
j parce qu'au fond c'est tellement
d'actualité juste cette semaine on va
avoir dit qu'il va aller en cour suprême
contre la loi 21 et les usages de la
clause dérogatoire qui permettait au
gouvernement de dire de manière
préventive on s'affirme comme ça même
chose de loi 96 alors si on est face à
un blocage sans fin qu'est ce qui arrive
c'est extrait pour venir à l'extrait
veut dire que mais c'est ce qui arrive
avec le danger d'une housse et qu' il
n'est pas interprété comme quelque chose
de collectif il était parti de thé comme
nous et la caq vraiment est devenu un
être dans ce genre de politique nous
posons des gestes d'affirmations mais
pour qui pour préserver surtout la
majorité historique francophone et les
gens qui sont issus de la minorité ne se
sentent pas inclus et ça donne quoi ça
ne sauve ça ne sauve pas le français ça
ne règle pas un problème de signes
religieux on n'en avait pas de problème
de signes religieux ouais mais deux
choses là dessus quand françois legault
dit au québec c'est comme ça qu'on vit
c'est peut-être maladroit mais ce qu'il
veut dire par là c'est pas des canadiens
français vivent comme ça ce qui veut
dire c'est tout le québec vit comme ça
et bien évidemment c'est la traduction
mais pourquoi on aurait honte de dire
c'est la traduction d'une commandite
d'une façon de vivre qui de qui depuis
longtemps est celle de la majorité
francophone pourquoi ne pourquoi avoir
honte de dire une chose pareille les
majorités historique dans les
démocraties ont évidemment leurs loisirs
on voit les derniers sondages qui
montrent à quel point la cac et a le
soutien de la traduit plus de 50 voilà
je pensais 53% de la majorité
francophone les autres partis saab et
c'est
pourquoi une majorité ne peut pas
s'affirmer et invités à être les gens à
parler la langue
adapté des valeurs comme elle
dépasserait encore faut-il parler les
avoir cette inclusion et parler aux
jeunes qu'ils soient même pas fils
d'émigrants soit parfaitement québécois
ils vont le dire aussi que la culture
qui les intéresse c'est une culture de
la différence le problème de parler
d'une housse y ait pas confié pas
conjuguer au pluriel c'est qu'on se
passe de la modernité c'est la diversité
le québec ne survivrait pas sans
accepter le métissage aussi simple que
ça jacques beauchemin mais le nous n'est
pas par définition fermé sur lui même
n'est pas par définition ethnique le
nous il part d'une composante
majoritaire et
il invite à lui tous ceux qui veulent se
joindre à lui c'est ça le nous québécois
c'est un nous qui est par définition
exclusif il serait fermé qu'ils ont
visités c'est un affront direct aux
femmes musulmanes du tout
21 c'est insultant un lieu de
rassemblement de la diversité c'est une
façon de vivre ensemble de manière
neutre à 12 jours en se concertant c'est
pour ça qu'il faut voir ce documentaire
qui va faire débat c'est certain demain
soir à d'autres humanité et c'est sur
tou.tv déjà je crois jacques beauchemin
a accepté avec madame beaudoin d'y
participer et avoir merci france est
tactile merci beaucoup à gauche
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit